I'm Jennifer shadi I'm here doing the
residency at the st. Louis chess club
for the next week so I'll also be
teaching next week classes I was also
here for a special project over at the
hall of fame the Queen within which is
an exhibit that you should all go see
it's about archetypes of the Queen in
chess some of you might not know this
but the Queen was actually the weakest
piece when chess began so actually the
wasn't even the Queen at that point was
the messenger to the king it was only
when Queen when the chest came to Europe
that the Queen became a female piece and
thus the Queen and even then she was
only only able to move one square at a
time so it wasn't until the 16th century
that she became the most powerful piece
on the board and of course it's really
speeded up the game of chess
because before without the Queen being
really powerful of course it would be
very difficult to checkmate the King
right you can imagine if you didn't have
a queen and you couldn't promote upon to
a queen how difficult it would to get
mate by comparison to today so that show
is all about archetypes as anybody has
seen it yet no ok yeah it's most of you
tonight are men and it is definitely a
more female centric show it's it's
really popular in the art and fashion
worlds but we also think that women and
girls will maybe become more interested
in chess because of it but that being
said I encourage you to take your
girlfriend's wide sisters anybody who's
trying to get into the game to show it
because it's really an amazing cultural
event in st. Louis people are coming all
in all over the world just to see the
Queen within because some of the
fashions haven't been displayed for for
a really long time since savage Beauty
at the mat so these are some of the the
fashions as you can imagine might be
difficult to play a chess game in I
really like that one
I think that is my favorite and if you
are
to design these pieces Hideki actually
was in town for these events he did that
one as well and this is actually a
famous dress of Beyonce and Naomi
Campbell both wearing it and that's also
worn by a chess player this is Carmen
Kass and she's a supermodel and she was
also the president of the Estonian Chess
Federation and a pretty decent player I
saw some some games some exhibition
games that she played and definitely has
played more than a hundred games of
chess in her life she's really studied
the game and impressive to have somebody
like her playing so I encourage you all
to check out the show and as usual the
Hall of Fame across the street kind of
brings to mind the question of beauty in
chess and art in chess
one example which I would like to show
you is a very famous game which is
called the gold coins game and I think
we got this all worked out and this game
played by Frank Marshall the famous
American champion played in Europe was
so beautiful that at the end of the game
gold coins were showered across the
board and when I was looking at those
dresses it reminded me of this position
so black to move inland and sorry - I
think two of you who I already showed
this to you but go through this a little
bit more quickly because I think some
people might recognize this position as
well this is one of the more famous
positions in chess history of course
it's gold coins game especially in
American chess history black to move and
win
when night check is not yet made it so
definitely moved to look at but the king
can go shuttle over to H Moana to escape
for me rather to escape from the jack
although it is an interesting motif you
know am I in another class somebody
suggested Queen takes e5 and I mentioned
that in this position if only this rook
were like let's say white place I'm
sorry like if omegas were queer we're
advanced already like let's say that
black just did something dumb here like
like that I need to make a really dumb
move for black like I'm having trouble
making a dumb enough move for black okay
there we go
I did it no no whoa that's a bad sign
though I have to try that hard that's
clearly not the best line and now black
has a really strong continuation yeah
force me anybody see I know Julian sees
in what's right Reed exactly so Brooke
takes h2 King takes h2 and then Rick h5
is made and the reason I needed to put
my my queen on 87 was because a lot of
those other squares or would be like a
way to block them eight or something or
obviously Queen sees having Queen d6
would actually be protecting h2 so just
to point out that there's a lot of rich
tactical possibilities in this position
as soon as you see like things like that
in the air it means that the position is
really ripe and you should be looking at
all your possibilities so when you see a
tactic that doesn't work you should
never think all that was a waste of time
because a lot of times the tactical
possibilities that you considered will
come up in another variation or similar
things will come up
any ideas I know a couple of you know it
you know it oh okay yeah turn it try to
avoid that
so think about the Queen within looking
for a spectacular moves like yeah it's
it's black smooth we looked in 92 check
well Knight f3 is definitely something I
would always look at because it's a
forcing move in at chatter is blacks
position but after pawn takes f3 it's
like not that clear right I'm you have
to have you have to take back with a
queen because your queen is now on take
and then I don't really see a clear
continuation there but it is a sacrifice
well yeah we're kept to as an
interesting idea because you're trying
to do some kind of combination of 92 and
work F 1 meeting but it's not the quite
quite the rate execution
so basically notice that those work on H
3 is deceptively powerful and in some
situations if this pawn were to be
removed it would cut off the king and
set up a meeting net on e tail so that's
actually kind of like one of the keys to
solving the position here we need to try
to construct a position where Knight e 2
would be checkmate
now if pawn takes g3 what would be the
maid here right 92 would just be
checkmate now what if they were to take
with the F pawn exactly that's also
mating and what if they were take with
the Queen
so if Queen takes what would what would
be your first instinct oh well that's
good I mean rook takes that would just
leave you down in exchange right you
know the exchange being down the
exchange is another way to say that
you're that what
but Julian you know this if I say I'm
down the exchange what does that mean oh
you don't know okay that's good you'll
learn something so if you're down the
exchange that means you're down
specifically a rook for a bishop for a
knight it's a par Lance that top players
use and it's kind of confusing because
it's in exchange is any trade in chess
but it's also specifically used to talk
about that material in balance probably
because it's a typical sacrifice right a
lot of times we sacrifice the exchange
so because we have a particularly
powerful Knight or bishop in exchange
for the rough I like the way they they
call it in French a little better I
think it's called an exchange of quality
because it gives a little bit more of an
insight into what it means
so after Queen taste III of course rook
g3 is not
to be very good because after pawn g3
were just down in exchange so instead
you mentioned Knight to e2 Jack and then
what would happen what would I white
have to play and then what exactly and
so that is the one of the most beautiful
moves
I guess that's debatable there's a there
I did a whole series on a website that I
edit chess life online us chests org and
I did a whole series I did a whole
series by two different authors and they
are both specialists in the history of
chess and the history of chess problems
and what they did is they found the most
beautiful chess move on each square so
there's two articles once about
positions that were actually played like
this one Marshall and I'm pretty sure
this is the position for g3 so basically
this would be the g3 square and then
they he'd find a beautiful game where
the finishing boat was on g4g etc and
then the other article is the same thing
but that's with composed problems which
I absolutely adore I'm not
I've never composed a chess position
myself but I think that chess problems
are really beautiful so there are two
series you can go look them up and
anyway this is definitely one of the the
best the most beautiful moves at least
one of the most beautiful moves on the
square g3 and as I mentioned to my I
mentioned previously the funny thing
about this was that there's some
argument over the gold coins that they
were actually not throwing gold coins to
celebrate the move but rather because
they were gambling on the game and they
were training 3d money and that's after
this move was played so I wanted to show
you a couple other beautiful finishes on
this one was played by the top women's
chess player in history you know who
that is Judah Judit Polgar the number
one female chess player in history still
she's been in the top four a woman's
chest for many many years and
even though there's a lot of people who
are closer like she used to be the best
buy so many rating points now you know
you've got a couple female players
who've reached 2600 but she was the only
one to ever reach 2700 so this is black
to motherland
so Queen to a four and then after a rook
takes a four okay four and then after
King V one right so a nice little
corridor slash back rank maid
I'll put it out on the board for
everybody to see so Queen a four and now
if King B 1 we also can play rock H 1 so
instead after rook takes a 4 ro K 4 and
the king is not able to go forward
because of the rock guarding it here
instead it goes backwards in our cage 1
and so really a variation on a
background check mate and that's the
thing I mean in chess the simplest
background check mates are something
that you learn and when you start the
game but as you become stronger the
background check mates are still part of
the game it's just that there are more
complicated permutations and more
extensive variations right so it's
always it's still the same tactics I
just gave a lecture to the advanced
class last night about and I did a
continuation from the intermediate to
the advanced class about Magnus Carlsen
and Michiana and their previous battles
because of course they're playing in the
World Championship in just a couple
weeks and you know we were looking at
some rapid and blitz games to be fair so
there were more mistakes in normal but
it's really amazing that you just see
all the same things double attack pins
it's all there and the beginner game all
the way up to super Grand Master just
more complicated variations of it and
that's why it's fun that even the most
elite games in the world can be broken
down into things that are interesting
for beginners this one is wait to move
how would you play in this position as
White
we give people another minute bye thank
you
but I'm glad these are proving somewhat
challenging for you that you're not
getting them absolutely instantly
julene what were you thinking and what
were you thinking you had your hand up
to behind what were you thinking okay so
Queen act 2 and then what's your idea
right and then uh-huh
and then after Queen up to like rook
takes F to Kim K except two exactly very
good so this is an interesting problem
because normally when we think of Queen
sacrifices which by the way I all the
problems so far have been Queen
sacrifices so that's like a hidden theme
here I didn't want to give it away at
the beginning because I thought that
would make the problems too easy but now
the cats out of the bag so by contrast
the others were all violent Queen
sacrifice it was like Queen g3 Queen a4
check and this one is a defensive move
right we're moving our Queen back to f2
which is the only good way to prevent
Queen G to mate and now this pawn is
unstoppable right so this material
balance a queen for two rooks is about
equal but this pawn is to be a queen and
there's just not enough checks to make
this a perpetual whites king can hide
especially since it's a four is
protected so totally winning white will
just simply move the bishop away and
queen the pond right and it's funny
because it's a it's such an it's in one
way it's an easy move to find but it's
also like not something you really think
of normally when you're trying to sack
you're trying to move forward and sack
right this one is black to move and win
let me let me wait for another person
but I'll ask you
you got it too few people got it good
all right um Julien work do you want is
that what you guys were thinking no or
are you thinking no working one of the
correct moves out what you think in the
back okay so what's your main line well
oh you wanted to play workings g2 we're
tasty to is not as strong because after
Bishop g2 queen f2 chat king h1 we're
kind of hiding a little bit where we're
surviving and your idea after work to be
one check what was your main line yeah
then Queen a7 check and then after king
h1 and then Kim Jiwon and then king h1
exactly so we get that that important
smother me right which I talked about a
little bit in the last class so now you
can't play queen a7 check right away
because the rook guards at square so
work do you one is a lovely a little
sacrifice we can't take with the bishop
because then it would just be made into
right queen f2 and queen F on so instead
we must take with a rock Queen Queen a7
check of course we can't come to f1
because of Queen f2 mate and one but
after teenage one night f2 check King g3
night h3 double check King F wanna leads
to mate in one again well there's king
h1 we get one of the prettiest mates in
jazz it's typical but it's also
extremely pretty that's a funny thing
right very you know sometimes people
like to think of rarity is beauty but in
reality diamonds are not very rare at
all and neither are smothered mates
right I'm still very beautiful I'm not
sure I think smother mates are more
beautiful than diamonds but that's just
me apparently most women don't feel that
way so don't try to get your fiance or
I'm sorry your girlfriend a smothered
name I don't think that'll work as well
anyway this is a really important
checkmate and hopefully y'all get to
deliver it one day like I said it's
extremely beautiful but it's not that
rare because this kind of motif happens
a lot especially when ye or black
obviously like most attacking lines it's
even more common for white to execute it
but it happens because white or black
weakens our diagonal a little bit right
or you wrench it open somehow and
usually that happens because whites
actually trying to do something
aggressive when you move you're a pawn
forward there's lots of openings from
the Kings gambit to the Grand Prix to
the four pawns attack where you're
voluntarily moving your F pawn it
weakens you but you're getting an
aggressive attack so that's that's kind
of the nature of the beast right on this
one's weight to move
yes Queenie seven and then if we're cafe
right and then work the eight so this is
just just a little prettier on its like
normally I don't see it in exactly this
iteration it's very typical to sacrifice
your rook I mean to sacrifice your queen
in order to get a background check mate
this is usually it happens in a slightly
different way and then if we're cafe we
can play rook d8 and we're waiting by
force view there's no way to further
protect f8 right so just mixing it up
with a slightly easier one in there all
right great
this one's white to move
second yeah wait one second
so we got a couple people who got the
answer
do you think you have it as well all
right what do you think Queen eat seven
and then after King ate seven and then
after King to h6
okay and then after King to g5 all
forest did everybody else get to this
position as well it's very important to
visualize if I put that position on the
board you'd all see the one you move
instantly but you got to kind of
memorize in advance you see the final
blah you do what's that
yeah it's always wonderful to checkmate
with a pawn isn't it right that's a
beautiful way to finish a game so Queen
takes h7 you notice that it's all for us
right King can't escape to h6 but after
what KJ h4 is a checkmate how many
people have mated with a pond before
somebody once asked me to play a game in
which I had they were there an ammeter
and they were like let's play a game and
you have to check meet me with a pawn
do you think that's possible like I
don't think that's I think that's too
hard yeah also I mean well that's that's
an interesting that's an interesting
thought because you can't make another
pawn yeah that's a really good idea yeah
yeah I don't think this is gonna be easy
for you obviously you'd have to play
somebody who's reasonably intelligent
and those are rules and as long as
that's the case I don't think you can do
it it's one thing like checkmate on a
specific square that's something that a
lot of people and hustlers and parks do
and I think that that's definitely
possible if you're playing against a
weak enough fire to arrange your
checkmate or no specific square but to
do with a pawn I don't think it's
possible but it's always very memorable
to checkmate with a bond oh this one's
very easy
yeah yeah just queen takes off eight and
then work g8 meeting I'm going to get
you to this one and this is why'd you
move
yeah
you actually have two ways to go about
it in this position anybody it's a queen
eight sevens one when you move what's
that
well queen of faders rook takes FA and I
don't see how you're gonna make that
work what's that
Queen G's have an or queen H oven
alright and after and after King takes
rook takes f7 and then after King g8
right exactly so that's a that's a mate
that you see a lot with a rook on FA but
here are the Bishop on c5 guards right I
personally find Queen g7 much more
aesthetic and now if we go to h6 it's
also just checkmate in one play work to
h7 so forced to go back and now after g7
King AJ Brigade 7087 mate
so I started this lecture by talking
about the Queen within and all the
lovely archetypes of the Queen and then
I spent the whole time showing you ways
to sacrifice the Queen I tried to do a
little little asymmetry there of course
the Queen sacrifice is always a
beautiful way to finish your chess games
and you know it's funny because I have
it in my book play like a girl I have a
chapter on Queen sacrifices but it's
really a tactic that isn't about Queen
sacrifice usually because about some
other element in the position right like
a lot of the time it's a smothered mate
or a back ranked mate and the Queen is
just the executor of that so it's a kind
of not really a tactic in itself more
method but as always one of the best
ways to get better at chess is to do
tactics and to recognize these patterns
quickly especially the ones that come up
all the time like some of these are a
little rare like these last two examples
that's not very typical but the back
ranked stuff that we looked at the
smother made those are really archetype
home it's just like we're talking about
archetypes across the street archetypal
finishes to the game